[Music]
hello and welcome I'm Edmund from square
and with me are Lac and you Feng from
Google we're gonna be talking to you
today about useful patterns for
developing operationalizing and
maintaining machine learning models
machine learning involves a few steps
from organizing your data you gather it
engineer your features create and train
the model and you finally deploy it but
it's actually iterative you need to
there you know there's an animation
there it's actually quite iterative you
need to first organize your data sorry
you're not done once you've trained and
deployed your model you need to
continuously monitor its performance add
features retrain periodically it's a
team effort involving data analysts data
engineers and data scientists typically
your subject matter experts data
engineers will gather all the data with
inputs from data scientists your data
scientists will join all the data create
the features create and train the model
and data engineers will be responsible
for maintaining the training prediction
infrastructure and everyone will monitor
model performance although different
aspects of it data analysts will be
focused on the outputs of the model
their distributions how actionable they
are whether they're enabling good
decisions or not data scientists will be
more focused on the distributions of the
inputs themselves any shifts in those
might represent a problem with your data
ingestion pipeline or maybe a shift in
the population and the data engineers
will be focusing on uptime and
resilience and thus because we have so
many people working on so many moving
parts simultaneously operation
operationalizing mo models is actually
quite difficult and now Lac is gonna
discuss some of those challenges
thanks Edmund yep so operationalizing an
ml model by which we mean after going
from a trained model to a model that's
deployed in production that you can use
to make predictions which that's hard
and that's like the chasm in our title
right there's this big chasm between
training a model and getting it into
production right so let's talk about
number one like oars number zero why is
it so hard to put a machine learning
model into production what makes it hard
means it's a software we know how to
deploy software so why me what is so
special about machine learning models
that it's so hard to put them into
production so first thing is this whole
concept of reproducibility the thing is
when you train your model what are you
training on you're essentially training
on historical data data that now is in a
data warehouse right you basically are
taking that data it's in your data
warehouse and then you're training your
model on it but when you come to
predictions
what are you predicting on you're not
making your predictions on data in the
data warehouse that's historical data
what you care about is predictions in a
real-time stream ready making
predictions on data that's coming in so
it may be software but these two are
different software systems you have one
software system that's about historical
data and data preservation and so on and
you have another software system that's
about you know real time that's about
getting things very quickly
that's about user interactivity it's
about speed right so they're very very
different kinds of systems and
everything that you do in the training
step has to be repeated in the
deployment step and that reproducibility
is very hard so we look at patterns that
help us get that reproducibility so that
the steps that you did during training
they you can basically repeat them a
repaired
use them in your deployment system the
second thing is that everything that you
do needs to be portable between the
training system and the deployment
system and unfortunately these two
things the hardware and the software are
often very different red you might train
on the cloud but you might do an
inference on a phone right at the same
that it may be the same software but the
software that runs on the cloud after
obviously a system is very different
that's something that's gonna run on the
phone right and if you need that you
need everything that you do all your ml
models all your ml systems to be
portable between the hardware and the
software that's actually different
between the training and inference
systems so we look at portability
patterns right ways to make sure that
things remain portable the third thing
is that whatever platform that you use
it needs to be flexible and the reason
it needs to be flexible is that your
skill sets on the training site and the
priorities on the training side are very
different from the skill sets and
priorities on the inference side right
on the training side who's doing the
training it's gonna be your data people
and what do they care about data number
one but they also care about things like
accuracy can I train on all the data
right that care about scale but in when
they talk about scale they're talking
about scale in terms of am I able to
scale to all my data they're talking
about research they're talking about
being able to use better models to be
able to use the most advanced models
that are available and they're also
talking about the models themselves
being able to have to basically
accommodate them so that's on the
training side so the priorities are in
terms of accuracy in terms of scale in
terms of being able to train on all
their data and the project rate their
skill sets tend to be things like
statistics and python and so on now look
on the other side on the inference side
who's doing the inference
it's your engineering team
what do they care about resilience they
don't want the thing to crash they don't
want the pager to go off right that's
the number one priority the priority is
very different they also care about
scale but the scale that an engineer
cares about is different from the scale
that your data scientist cares about
your data scientist wants to train on
all the data the engineer wants to make
sure that they can handle all million
users that are going to hit your webpage
at lunch time right the scale that
they're talking about is very different
they've care about the engineering
quality they care about maintainability
they care about speed they care about
applications right so the priorities and
skill sets are different and so if you
pick a machine-learning platform any
platform you pick has to be flexible to
accommodate both of these types of users
and finally you need to basically deal
with agility and that's kind of a joke
but you kind of know you train your
model and historical data you train your
model and things that look like
dinosaurs and then you start running
your model and they basically are dealt
with birds right the data has drifted as
evolved over time and you basically get
something that is kind of the same thing
but not quite the same thing and you
need that agility to deal with this
model drift because guess what the
real-world things change over time so no
that thing the thing that you trained on
and the thing that you're predicting on
there is going to be model drift and the
question is how do you recognize it how
do you accommodate for it how do you fix
it so anything that in so we look at
patterns that deal with agility so first
to talk about reproducibility patterns
so first one so what are some of the
ways that we basically get
reproducibility okay so first thing this
is what we talked about you train on
historical data you predict on real time
streaming data so how do you deal with
that
you want to basically reuse your
pipeline your data pipeline your data
pre-processing as much as possible
between your batch historical system and
your streaming real-time system to date
there is still only one system one API
that allows you to do data processing
with the same code on both batch and
stream right and that's beam Apache beam
in fact the B II is right it's B is for
batch and EAMS for stream right so it's
about a single consistent thing that
lets you deal with that end stream so
that you can basically have the same
code and in our case we run Apache beam
on Google Cloud and data flow that's why
you see data flow in the diagram there
but the code that you write is open
source is Apache beam so pattern remove
one Apache beam to reuse this pipeline
code between training and inference so
the reason that we do this right is
because all the data transformations
that you need to do on the training data
set they have to get applied during
inference too right so you take your raw
data you pre-process it you clean it you
create features and it is these features
that you give to your trading model and
now your training model needs to
basically do predictions and so you take
that trained model and you deploy it but
to that deployed web application what
comes about is essentially the raw
inputs that the clients need it's
exactly the same data that they need the
question now is how are we going to do
this pre-processing and feature creation
so that reproducibility is
super-important how do we reproduce
everything that we did in a training
system on the inference side so there
are couple of ways to do it
if for example you do pre-processing and
tensorflow you can do this reproduction
right so you have your pre-processing
coding of your feature feature creation
code and then you create your pre
process features and you train your
model on them it is very efficient and
if you are using the
Demeter API you basically have some
things called feature columns and
everything that you do in a feature
column will be remembered in the tensor
flow graph so when you checkpoint a
tensor flow model all of those
pre-processing steps are saved in the
graph so that when you then go out to go
predict it
it's automatic all of those steps that
you did get carried out because you used
feature columns so that is great but
there are a couple of caveats here the
first caveat is that it's only things
that you do in a future column is only
things that you use tensorflow methods
with what if you did pre-processing that
doesn't happen in the future column now
you have to deal with it some other way
the second thing is and this is a very
general high-level restriction your
tensor flow model when you train it what
does it see it essentially sees a batch
of examples but in essence it only sees
one example at a time
it doesn't actually see a no historic
samples in order right so any of the
pre-processing that you do on that one
training example is fine but if your
pre-processing involves a moving average
will you ever have a moving average as
an input sure right if you ever have a
moving average that moving average the
way you compute the moving average
there's nothing you can do inside the
tensor flow feature transform to do that
it doesn't work because the tensor flow
model only sees that one example it
doesn't know how you computed that
feature in the first place so there is
that that second issue so it's efficient
but it's restricted to tensor flow
methods in a feature column and it's
only that one input the other approach
that you can do is that you can do this
thing in a patchy beam so that's what I
just showed you right you do it in that
beam pipeline you do your actual
pre-processing you compute your moving
average in a patchy beam
so that's great it has state you
computed in Python you computed in Java
and you compute that feature and you
train your model on the feature then
when you're doing a predictions you run
the exact same pipeline to create the
exact same moving average and you give
it your model so this way now it sees a
full data set right it scales really
well because it's beam is distributed
but it cannot take advantage of
accelerators what do mean by
accelerators GPUs TP use etc this is
okay if there is a moving average it's
not okay if you're basically running the
first half of the Inception model right
to basically create an embedding that
you're basically using as an input your
model now that creating that feature is
so expensive you can't really do that in
something like B so how do we basically
do reproducibility that kind of combat
it's for both of these things and that's
what T have transformed us so tensorflow
transform is a library that is a hybrid
of Apache beam and tensorflow
how is it a hybrid you do your analysis
during training in Apache beam so you
can look at all your data set you can
compute your moving averages
you can find your mins and maxes you can
find your unique values you can do all
of those things in beam and then at
prediction time in tensor flow you can
actually apply those transformations so
you get the scale of beam and you get
the efficiency of tensor flow right and
everything is remembered from what you
did during training to what you need to
do during prediction so pattern number
one for reproducibility tensor flow
transform
so you basically get us said the
efficiency of transit ordering inference
and the scalability of beam during
training so it's not just beam it's not
just tensorflow it's that right
combination of the two the second thing
that you want to think about when it
comes to reproducibility guts back into
the development of the model itself and
this is where you want to make sure that
you are never copying data because every
time you make a copy of data you run
this risk that the thing that you train
on and the thing that you're going to
predict on there have been other things
that have happened in the middle so one
of the things that we always suggest is
keep your data in bigquery you can share
the data set you can share your queries
in bigquery you can actually save your
data on cloud storage and you can run a
federated query so you can run your
sequel query on the data that exists
already in cloud storage or in cloud
BigTable or on Google Drive but the
point being don't make copies of your
data
don't move your data around keep your
data in place join it in place share the
datasets share the queries so that
different people can run different
analytics on it so join your data in
place don't move it around so if you
have structured data if you have
streaming data use bigquery if you have
archival data unstructured data use
cloud storage if you have transactional
data time series data internet-of-things
data used cloud BigTable if you have
business types of data spreadsheets etc
use Google Drive and the cool thing is
that all of these things you can run a
federated query on so you can keep your
data in place and not have node make
copies of it and by not making copies of
it you can limit your reproducibility
problems and then you can access that
same data with different kinds of tools
so as we just talked about you can do
federated curves with bigquery but you
can use dataflow and Apache Beam so you
can do your batch and stream processing
so you explore your data in bigquery
and then you train and you predict with
dataflow you haven't changed the data
you haven't moved the data so you don't
have to worry that this data that you
explored and this data that you're
training again are actually different so
you can do data proc hadouken SPARC
workloads machine learning etc and this
allows you to democratize your data
insights across your org you can save
and share your queries you create good
reports with bigquery you can share them
as sheets you can use partner tools like
tableau looker etc to share this data
but the key principle here is keep the
data in place do your analytics with
multiple tools but don't move your data
around and to talk about how Square does
this Edmund so the rules governing how
much Square should pay it's financial
partners for processing any given
payment are extremely Byzantine they're
scattered across multiple rule books
with each card network concurrency
having its own book some of these books
over a thousand page long and they
change twice a year every April in
October so it's actually quite difficult
for us to know how much we should be
paying for anyone any one payment it's
far too difficult to generate and
maintain a rules engine so what we've
done is we've created a machine learning
model to verify a course for us the
transaction cost anomaly detector or
Tcat oh sorry through-and-through t CAD
we've discovered over 2 million dollars
worth of transaction anomalies one of
much of it was recoverable because they
were bonafide transact transaction cost
errors and a large part of receiving
that result has been living training
serving skew which we've done by using
the same queries using the same bigquery
tables have training and inference there
for both times reusing the same data
we've also performed all of our
pre-processing with in tensorflow using
the TF feature column module and this
ensures that at training and inference
we're we're using the same vocabularies
for at ago
Oracle features same scaling for our
numeric features this is work quite well
for us but it does require us to first
define these vocabularies to find these
numeric ranges and encode them in our
model in future iterations we're most
likely going to be moving towards
tensorflow transform to further simplify
this process now another pattern that
we've been using in T CAD is portability
and to see that let's take a look at the
Tcat architecture itself now let's start
at the top left with the training we
have our historical cost data stored in
bigquery and we're training with that
data on ml engine and then when it comes
time for inference which is the lower
half of this diagram we have our Train
model stored in cloud storage and we
have a data pipeline cloud dataflow
pipeline which also takes our historical
cost data from bigquery the same sources
training and computes or estimates what
our true cost should be compares that
against their actual cost compiled
computes aggregates passes them all
along to stock driver where we have
dashboards and alerts and if necessary
additional human review and further
action this is all been working great
for us but we didn't start with that we
have to go from an on-premise solution
to a complete cloud solution where we
moved all our data to bigquery we moved
our storage to Google Cloud Storage and
we moved our inference and data
processing pipeline to dataflow but all
along the way we were able to retain the
same tensorflow model
thanks Edmund so as Edmund said right
the key idea is that is this holiday of
portability that they were able to make
all these changes but at the bottom of
it they were able to keep the exact same
transfer flow model and that's one thing
that I think you keep hearing over and
over again is this idea of being able to
do poor porting from on-prem to cloud
from from your cloud to your device etc
and Ted's flaw is a big part of
providing that portability so why do we
need portability okay when we design
tensorflow
this whole idea was that we needed to
support different training and inference
environments so when you talk about
where do you train you might train on
the cloud you might train on a
kubernetes system right you might train
with programs written in Python
tensorflow solve Python primarily you
know the training code might need
accelerators like GPUs or your custom
ASIC chips like tensor processing units
so you need that portability that
happens the fact that training happens
on all these kinds of environments then
you go over to the inference side where
do people do reinsurance where did they
run predictions well they may run
predictions in cuban artists they may
run it on gke with kubernetes engine
they may run it as part of a web
application they may write it in mobile
devices they might run it on javascript
how many of you heard of tensorflow on
javascript tensorflow jeaious right
that's part of the portability idea you
train the model on the cloud but you run
it inside your web browser right you run
it with Java you run it so it the fact
that Ukraine did create Liam arbalet
Python doesn't mean that you have to run
it in a Python system right that's a
very key important design goal behind
tensorflow is to support all these
different training and inference in
inference environments so the pattern
here is use tensorflow tensorflow is
what gives you that portability and in
terms of these environments I like to
think of it as three different types of
environments you have the environments
that are all about simplicity
right you have a fully managed cloud ml
engine everything is you don't have to
spin up a cluster you just submit your
tensor flow code and you have your model
trained or if you want to do development
of a model and you just want and a VM
with tensor flow and Jupiter and
everything that you would typically need
as in data science you want all of that
directly installed there is a deep
learning image you can go to the club
launcher page launch they launch a deep
learning image and it basically has
different versions of tensorflow
different different GPUs that you can
attach to it and you can basically get
going so that's the simplicity end of it
on the fast side of things you want to
do things very very very fast you want
to train very fast you know the cloud TP
use you have GPUs on the cloud but in
between you might need portability you
might need things you may need to run
inference not on the cloud and that's
where cube flow comes in cube flow is
tends to flow in Q Burnett is an open
source project led by Google and then
you have tensorflow which runs in Python
and C++ in JavaScript in Java tensorflow
Lite which runs on mobile devices so you
have all of these different choices and
third to talk about flexibility you
think okay so we've talked about our
first two points flexibility comes in
kind of almost in when you reverse
around instead of saying for the same
model if I switch the world around the
model what happens there's also the
consideration of when it comes time to
change the model how can we do that
without then altering the world around
that model significantly so when it
comes to model building there's a very
wide library of choices now right
there's lots of different libraries you
can use to build your model you can use
I could learn you can use XP boost
Kerris tensorflow
and many others there's also the
tensorflow hub if you haven't seen that
I would really encourage checking that
out too you have hub it's a really neat
place to kind of see the different
models that folks are building
the hope is that you'll not only be able
to get value out of the TF hub to get
models that are out in the community
research models things like that but
also then be able to contribute back to
the community things that you have found
that new models that you've developed
and so whether you're building just your
standard fully connected networks or
convolution networks or more
sophisticated things like recurrent Nets
and things like that having flexibility
in what model you use because sometimes
you might start with one do your initial
analysis and then for the same type of
data change fundamentally the kind of
model you're using so that means you you
want to think about what kind of
interface your model is providing to
your downstream consumers such that
you're able to swap things out right
just general good software engineering
practices when it comes to layers of the
abstraction and things like that and the
other thing I want to note is that
Kerris is now also part of tensorflow so
you can call TF carrots I think it was
1.8 and above that supports that and
that there's interesting ways now you
can combine model building using carrots
so Kerris has a really great simple
model building API that is really easy
to use and you can combine that with
tensor flows execution speed and
estimated are frameworks you can stick
Karis model inside an estimator and then
run that which gives you two access to
distributed training accelerators all
without having to rework the wiring of
your model and so that brings us to kind
of the next point right where do you
hook up the model to and the
considerations around having flexibility
in the consumption of your data there's
really highly structured data right it
may come from a variety of different
sources and as you experiment with the
type and amount of data you feed your
model during this training process this
iterative process you might find that
you either need to add more data change
from your one data set to another or add
something in and that it might go from
fitting into memory and being really
easy to do on a laptop to being
something
a larger or maybe you go from having
unstructured data that's in a data lake
and you move to structured data and then
you have to think about how you can
import that data over and connect that
in so having flexibility in how your
model consumes the different types of
data that it may encounter through its
lifetime is an important design decision
as you go about kind of this task right
swapping out models swapping out data's
and thirdly the notion of being able to
iterate quickly so this is a kind of a
specific note for more complex models
and when I say complex models I don't
just mean models that are in themselves
a sophisticated quote unquote but also
situations where you have a requirement
where you need to train a large amount
of data and run that through the model
during training before you can get a
meaningful outcome or to even know if
your training is kind of going in the
right direction and so for that you want
to be able to train and iterate with a
reasonable amount of speed and there's a
couple ways that you can achieve speed
right if you say well creating
iterations are fast for me because each
time I do a new training cycle it only
takes 30 seconds great you're all set
and so you can just try something try
something try something in series but
what if each time you do a training
cycle after you've already max out all
your options when it comes to compute
resources it still takes 30 minutes or
30 hours to do one training iteration
that's when it comes times to think
about other ways you have to think
outside of just doing one attempt and
then a different attempt and moving on
and so being able to kick off multiple
training jobs in parallel that are
isolated from each other such that you
can experiment across a spectrum of
different models different parameters
and potentially even different features
right different input data
that go into your model and so one kind
of plug I'll make here is that cloud ml
engine supports kind of these various
facets of quick iteration when it comes
to larger datasets and bigger
training jobs you can train multiple
jobs you kick off a job you configure it
with your model you feel your data and
it's off to the races and then you can
set up another one right you kick off
another job and you can choose to use
the same data set or maybe a different
data set same model a different model
etc and you can kick off multiple
training tasks but then with each
training task itself you can also
configure different hyper parameter tune
yeah different hyper parameters so
there's a built-in 2ml engine a hyper
parameter tuning service called hyper
tune fittingly and it will basically try
out different variants of the same model
and try to help you guide you in which
set high parameters would be most
appropriate and it basically do these in
parallel so you're kicking off parallel
jobs each parallel job is kicking off
parallel jobs in itself and so you're
getting this incredible scaling effect
and making yourself super super
productive which means you can just you
know go make a sandwich or something at
that point okay so the other piece of
flexibility I want to play out when we
talk about model building now we flip
over to deployment and we're making
predictions making inference there's a
couple of different options and things
you want to keep in mind right one is
model stacking once your model is
deployed it may be in a situation where
you actually have the outputs of one
model feeding in as inputs to a second
model and maybe that models outputs
feeding into a third model and at first
you might look at this and say you know
that's that's too sophisticated I'm not
gonna have three models feeding each
other that's silly but a lot of times
the things that we do in the
pre-processing step can actually be
thought of in this context what is the
first thing that happens to your data
when you make some of these
transformations depending on what they
are if they're not something super
trivial like the time series averaging
right if you're doing something a little
more sophisticated then you could think
of it as you are kind of modeling your
data in some way right and that might
change and you're going to need that to
show up in the in development deployment
as well and so when you have that
situation
you know the interface between your
different models they need to not
encounter bottlenecks because at
deployment time any bottleneck starts
really accruing and your latency starts
building up like crazy and then the
second point is swapping out models your
data science team goes and they've
developed model here I'm calling it
model 4 because it's the next number and
then they you know a couple weeks later
they're like hey we found some new data
you know the it looks kind of different
and we decided to try out a totally
different model the interface is kind of
similar but it's a different model it's
really different and so we need to swap
it out live can we do that all right so
what happens when we want to swap in
model 5 like that and still have
everything keep working and so if you're
in a situation where you you should be
able to do that that's something you
have to engineer up front because if you
don't and you need to do that you're
going to be in a hole and thirdly
scaling the inference writes more
predictions when you have more lots and
lots of requests standing up a
production server is no easy feat but
standing up multiple really quickly
because lots of requests are coming in
is arguably even harder and so the other
side of ML engine aside from the
training and the GPUs and the TP use and
all that awesome stuff is that you can
take an export a tensor flow model and
just give it a name and point to it and
say here I'm Ellen did take that model
and deploy it for me and auto-scale that
for me and yes I would also like a REST
API for that and obviously it should be
secured and you just can just take all
those things for granted you literally
just give it a name put down the path to
the file and click Save
so with that I'll pass it over to Edmund
to talk a little bit about kind of how
some day implements kind of flexibility
that's square so 2.75%
it's what squares famous for it's what
we charge for processing in person card
payments but as you can see from the
smaller text below that we actually
offer custom rate packages as well and
generating those custom rate packages
relies on model staff
ding and model choice let's start and
walk through this diagram backwards
actually let's begin from the top right
with two point four eight percent that's
our custom rate package
what made it a Karass model did a Karass
model that accepted inputs that
information that our sales team is
gathered through their dialogue with the
prospective seller that Karis model
itself was trained on cob machine
learning engine and here's robot the
model stacking happens one of the inputs
to this Harris model is actually a
separate model a word embedding that
we've actually used through a few other
models as well one of the other patterns
that we're gonna talk to today is
agility with right so so next kind of
thing the final of our four is agility
right lack introduced it with the
example of dinosaurs and birds or eagle
in that case and the implication here
being that the world changes that's
that's why you're all here right because
machine learning has put down some
sweeping changes on the landscape of
computing the landscape of Technology so
a couple of kind of models and mental
models for thinking about how we can be
agile when it comes to data and when it
comes to machine learning the first is
failing fast right when you have new
ideas finding ways to test out those new
ideas quickly and cheaply right so if
you have a new idea for an architecture
for a house maybe you build it out of
ginger house maybe you don't you use a
CAD software or something but I chose to
build a gingerbread house and that's
that's what happened there so apologies
for that and when you want to fail fast
what you can do is take a subset of your
data write this new data that client
comes in you're like oh let me try this
out let me see if I can get anything
useful out of it but it's not enough to
just randomly sample
some new data in a lot of cases you want
to be selective in pulling out a
particular subset of that data the part
that is particularly interesting to you
just because you know that this new data
in aggregate is something that is new
something that is different from what
you've seen before it doesn't
necessarily mean that a random sample
will bring about some kind of new
insight for you but if you already know
something about the nature of this new
data use it use it to your advantage and
kind of query your data out and export
of chunk of it that is representative of
what it is you're trying to evoke the
second aspect of agility is to basically
keep developing right just because the
model is in production does not mean
you're done in fact you've just started
you've just gotten across the starting
line I have a model in production now
it's doing stuff but now we want to
continue to improve that model
especially with this new live data the
example of the dinosaur data and the
bird data is interesting because once
you start build your models in
production and the new live data is
coming in as soon as that happens the
new data is now your historical data if
you can take that new data and then
utilize it to upgrade or update your
models going forward let's say you
deploy your model and two months later
you're able to take that two months
worth of data and do something useful
with it then you can improve your
existing models you can't you don't need
to just use the historical data from the
past past you kind of have the recent
past and finally kind of frequent
retraining this notion of there once in
awhile you might need to just blow it up
and start over
and that that's okay because whether
it's a new model right you might train
it on a new model or you might say you
know this model has been trained on data
from the past five years but we started
by training the data from like the older
three of those five years and then the
past two
years that the model has been in
production we've updated an updated and
updated but there's a lot of kind of
cruft
it's almost like we were developing a
software system right you you build that
initial release and then over the next
two years you add patches you put some
duct tape here you add some string over
there and at the end of two years it
doesn't even look like the thing you
originally designed and so maybe you
start over you you build over here
you're saying you know let's start and
say if I wanted to build this from
scratch today what how would that look
like what I still use the same models
what I still even use the same features
as machine learning a field that's
moving so quickly now as that kind of
progresses it will likely change the
answers to those questions and
relatively quickly and so concretely
what that often amounts to is taking
your deployed model and having something
like model versioning right we all have
software versioning we have kit and
things like that so we should also do
the same with model models and one of
the key benefits of this is being able
to rollback when you deploy a new
version of a model you want to be able
to say oops
I'd actually no I don't want that one
let me go back to the old one real quick
or maybe you deploy it and it works and
then the weekend comes and then you
realize your model doesn't generalize to
the weekend so then you roll back maybe
you have three new models and different
teams made them and they are competing
for saying 'hey it should be mine then
the other team also says no no it should
be ARMA our model is better so split
testing being able to divert your
traffic in an appropriate manner across
different models to say which model is
actually the better or more useful model
and so the and the second point here is
in terms of staying agile is thinking of
your system in this kind of chain right
from training all the way to deployment
all these different levels of the
abstraction that you have access to you
might start by working with something
like a pre trained model or something
from TF
something that is already you know
well-documented well-maintained and
established as a model that works and as
you go along as time passes you might
become more sophisticated in your
approach and customize that model and
maybe you then you know retrain it and
do all these things but having good
layers of abstraction allow you to make
these changes without kind of colliding
with yourself and so to talk a little
more about agility and how they've
approached that square turn it back over
to Edmund so what's this screen here
it's the decline screen it's what our
sellers and the customers see when
everyone our financial partners declines
a transaction we don't like seeing the
screen it represents a lost sale for our
sellers and for us it's lost revenue
from missing on a facility facilitating
that sale in order to minimize declines
we're actually working on automatically
retrying declines but each decline has a
cost so clearly we don't want to retry
everything because some of those retries
will inevitably decline themselves but
we do have a model to help us decide
which ones to retry now this diagrams a
lot simpler than the other ones I've
shown to you and there's really only two
key points here the first is that
inference is done in our payment systems
which are written in Java the training
was done in Python using a tension flow
premade classifier and what that has
allowed us to do is to go from nothing
to handing off a trained model to the
engineering teams to integrate into our
payment processing systems and while
they're working on integrating that
system I'm free to continue to collect
more data to refine our model and to
refine our decision criteria and finally
when it comes time to swap models in and
out for testing it's just one line of
code that needs to be changed
not much
all right so to kind of summarize them
parents who develop our professional
eyes and maintain ml models number one
need to exactly reproduce the training
steps in your deployment system and as
admin pointed out right
the idea is to limit the training
serving SKU in the machine learning
model so use identical bigquery queries
use tensorflow feature columns use
tensorflow transform the second pattern
is to be portable between different
hardware and software used for training
and inference and the point of that is
to basically use a system a free machine
learning framework that offers you that
portability don't go for the next new
shiny thing like there's there's there's
value in basically going with something
that's mature that's supported on a
variety of different platforms the third
aspect of this is basically allowing for
flexibility in model development and
model deployment so the idea there is
basically to be able to change models to
be able to basically stack models
together to be able to basically do all
of these things to be have different
versions of a model all these are very
very very important in a production
system and when you design a machine
learning system you should plan for your
model to go obsolete for things to be
changed and make sure that your client
code doesn't rely on a very specific
model but it's basically acting on it
through a layer of layer of indirection
and finally there's a idea of staying
agile to be able to iterate and to
deploy updates as as Edmund pointed out
I mean their idea was to basically give
their engineering team an initial
version of a model and then go ahead and
keep collecting data to create the next
better model that's a great way to
approach it right so don't think that
you have to build it all at once but
understand that as new data come in
you're going to basically get a newer
and better model but you have to have
something out there immediately right so
don't let the perfect be the enemy of
the good
so to summarize then these are the
patterns that we talked about for
reproducibility portability if
flexibility and agility number one
joining your data in place
sharing queries sharing datasets
pre-processing your data using Apache
beam and TF transform running tensor
flow and hybrid environments thinking
about training on the cloud predicting
on the edge gaining flexibility with
cloud with cube flow building the right
abstraction level and machine learning
and building in the ability in your
systems to be able to rollback model
versions and to continuously retrain
machine learning models thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]